welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and now that the
Matrix reboot is right around the corner
it's time to see how deep the
rabbit-hole really goes with Keanu
Reeves and carrie-anne moss officially
returning to the roles of neo and
Trinity for the upcoming film many are
wondering how they're both still alive
but bit of an early spoiler there anyway
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the best theories on how the
characters will return and what could be
happening in the film this includes a
matrix within a matrix neo being a
program the Matrix movies being movies
in the Matrix and yeah some crazy crazy
stuff you have a choice here you can
either take the red pill and potentially
have certain things about the movie
spoiled or you can take the blue pill
which which is viagra either way we will
be talking about various elements of the
series so far so if you want fully
caught up then now's the time to turn
off if you're still here thanks for
clicking the video now let's get into
our theories on how neo is alive in the
matrix reboot do you believe that my
being stronger or faster has anything to
do with my muscles in this place you
think that's air you're breathing now
okay so the last time we saw neo was at
the end of the Matrix Revolutions after
the character was assimilated by Agent
Smith
because neo was connected to the source
through a direct line it was able to
delete the villain and all of his
duplicates the series as a whole was
full of biblical metaphors and the
trilogy ended with the christ-like
figure being carried away by machines
showing his transaction from his body
into the spirit neo was pretty much dead
but similar to Christ there was lip
service paid to the fact that he could
rise again and this was given further
weight in the closing scene of
revolutions sati asked Oracle if we
would ever see him again and she said I
suspect so meaning that there is indeed
precedents for his return now the first
theory actually ties in quite a bit with
the Oracle and sati themselves during
the trilogy we learn that both
characters and in fact a range of others
are programs themselves that have
evolved in certain ways broken free of
the system and carved out their own
lives the death of Gloria foster who
originally played the part of the Oracle
forced the producers of the movie to
recast the role and they put it in the
hands of Mary Alice this shows that it
is possible for programs to change their
appearance so is possible at neo is
himself a program and that his
appearance has been selected for a
specific reason
this would allow him to return and it
would blow my mind if he was actually
part of the machine forces this would
massively subvert expectations and it
could be a plan by them to control the
humans by appearing as their Savior
where this falls down is that I can't
really see the Wachowski siblings
bringing the character back just to pull
the rug out from under our feet
personally I can't see it but it is
indeed a possibility hence why I've
included it the second theory is
slightly more straightforward and it
states that neo will come back to life
much in the same way that he came back
to life in the initial film people tend
to forget that neo has already died
before and the final few scenes of the
first film revolved around his death and
resurrection
during the climactic chase scene agent
Smith actually managed to get ahead of
neo and he killed him before he was able
to exit the matrix neo returned after
Trinity said that he couldn't be dead
because the Oracle prophesized that she
would fall in love with the one and
after kissing him he came
back after returning he was finally able
to break the barriers of the illusion
and he fully gained the powers of the
one the matrix is all about progression
within the mind to surpass the confines
of reality in order to move beyond it
neo came back to life and thus became
more powerful however he did have some
abilities before that allowed him to do
certain things in the matrix many
thought impossible in the sequels this
went beyond just the matrix as well and
in the real world he was able to stop
sentinels just by using his mind similar
to the matrix his powers had moved
beyond the confines of reality and it is
possible that he had once more
transcended to a certain point in which
he was above all else this could mean
that at the end of revolutions we just
saw another face of this and much in the
same way that the character died in the
first film he once more has come back
possessing the full abilities of the one
in the real world it's an interesting
theory and a very simple one too that I
think would quickly get the setup out of
the way and allow us to move into the
main plot so it is possible that we
could see this in the final result
another possibility that sort of ties in
with this theory is that Zion was just
another level within the matrix it could
be possible that Zion was just another
false reality that allowed some rebels
to inhabit it and believe that they were
free so we have a matrix within a matrix
that lets the machines harvest those
that are part of it this would not only
show how neo was able to return but also
how he was able to stop the Sentinels it
too explains how Oracle knew that he
would return and thus there's a lot of
weight to the theory the path of the one
is almost like a preordained program
itself so if this is the case it would
explain how neo was able to follow this
whether this turns out to be true or not
there is another theory which flashes
this up further and it states that the
versions we have seen in leaked images
as another incarnation of the Warner
that just so happens to look like Keanu
Reeves in the Matrix Reloaded neo comes
face to face with the architect aka the
creator of the matrix he informs the
protagonists that he's actually version
number 6 of the one and that there have
been several iterations of the matrix
itself each one had different aspects to
them but they all contain an anomaly in
the code which led to the creation of
the one so there is precedent for there
being multiple versions of the matrix
and multiple versions of the one now we
never find out who these other versions
are or
what they look like and it is possible
that the one always looks like Jana
Reeves because their appearance is
pre-selected we know that a younger
version of Morpheus is being cast for
the reboot so it is possible that the
creative team are doing a lot of things
with time and showcasing how the
consistencies remain in each version of
the matrix at the end of revolutions we
do start to see a new matrix form so it
is likely that this will have its own
version of the one which could once more
look like Keanu Reeves it's a really
interesting theory and I could
definitely see it popping up before we
get into the final theory which is the
craziest one yet I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the nfinity saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be and
when the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and the updates in the
comment section below the one it's gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of March
in the cell be shipped out from the int
over gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part ok so if
this final theory turns out to be true
then it could mean that we are all
within the matrix the theory says that
the new film will actually be set in our
world and that the Matrix movies will be
movies within the matrix to trick people
into thinking that they're not in the
matrix yeah my head's nearly exploded
Keanu Reeves and carrie-anne moss will
be playing well Keanu Reeves and
carrie-anne moss and someone would come
to tell them that they were part of the
film's because it would trick the world
into thinking that the matrix was
fictional and therefore not something
that were all stuck in Keanu Reeves
would then realize that he's actually
the one and he would reunite with
cariann to get to the bottom of what's
really going on they would be angered by
the fact that they were used as puppets
to spread propaganda and therefore use
their resources to break out the system
it's a crazy crazy theory and very
fourth wall breaking and it would also
completely remove the need to explain
why Nia was alive the behind the scenes
images that we've seen and make it look
like Jana Reeves and Carrie Amasa
training and therefore it could be them
coming to grips with their abilities in
a world that they believed was real the
matrix loves to have big reveals in it
and if this theory is true then I can
see it completely breaking people's
minds and then making us question or
reality much in the same way that the
first film did it's a really inspired
choice I think and out of the theories
it's definitely my favorite one it would
also explain how a younger Morpheus type
car
there is in the movie and the film
itself can explore the maitre corbeau
that is being made to try and trick
humanity once more I think it might be
to matter to make it to the movie but
with over 20 years since the first
film's release
the Wachowski have had their time to
think about things like this and Alvis
deeply as they can The Matrix is all
about simulations and how we've been
tricked into one and I can definitely
see this pleasing a lot of fans if it
turns out to be true now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
theories and which one you think is the
truth if you haven't even better one
then make sure you leave it in the
comments section below as I'm sure many
people have their own ideas and how the
characters could be coming back if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
breakdown of an exclusive Batman leak
that we got from an insider close to the
project we discuss where the plot is
pulling from and what the vengeance tile
that was spotted on set means so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey will click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe huge thank you for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]